good morning believe nation today's
message is find who you are over to you
Gwen Stefani what did I do consistently
to get to this point and I think that
would be to be really clear about Who I
am and to go with that and not try to be
something that you're not you'll stick
out because we're all very very
different but yet all the same I think
that you know it's weird because in the
early days like everything was so
homemade there was nobody telling us
what to do or how to do things nobody
telling me how to put my makeup on or
how skinny to be or what costume to wear
what song to write and I think that was
a really important thing because it
means that we were really our selves I
think the inspiration just came from
like the creation you know like to be
able to create and express yourself I
truly think people need to like just go
inward and go what what do I like Who am
I you know there's been people that have
been fans of like Julie Andrews or
Emmylou Harris there's a band called
fishbowl and that we used to go to all
their shows and of course but I honestly
say that like you know really it's all
about like finding who you are I think a
lot of people don't invest enough time
in finding out who they are it is so
hard to set your goals when you don't
know what it is that you want it's also
really challenging to live a life that
is fulfilling when you don't know what
truly makes you happy you see the reason
why I notice because I went through it
myself
I spent a large chunk of my life being
very miserable and I never invested the
time to find out why and on top of all
that I was so embarrassed because I
because I had a good life I was ashamed
to tell anybody that I was
instead I put on a seat front and I
continue to on with my day until one day
something devastating happened to me my
grandmother passed away
and I remember finding out in abacus and
uber and I spelled a pain so strong that
I would never forget that night and half
of that pain was the fact that I loved
her and I cared about her and I want and
I wanted to see her again but I knew I
wouldn't be able to but the other half
was the absolute poison of regret and
not living my life in the happiest
possible way that I can so the next day
I decided to do something really really
drastic I started asking myself really
difficult question I asked myself what
is it that was making me so miserable
and it was my job the jobs that I've
been working at for 10 years with making
me absolutely miserable then I asked
myself a question why did you choose
this job I had to honestly ask answer it
by saying I chose a job because I
thought it would make me a lot of money
why is it so important to make a lot of
money well I thought I could buy things
and having things means I have a higher
social status well why is it so
important to have a high social status
then I would be accepted and loved
[Music]
[Applause]
so really I wasn't after the money I
wasn't after the job I wanted to be
loved and accepted that's all I cared
about and it was such a liberating
experience because I had that in my life
I had that in my husband my husband
helped me accepted me for who I was in
everything that I was I have friends who
accepted me and loved me unconditionally
so I didn't need this job you see and I
didn't need the money so I decided to
quit my job shortly after and I took on
another job that was a lot less stress
and it opened up a lot of time for me to
do the things I cared about and loved
and one of the things that I absolutely
love is being a dance teacher I love
going into my classes and teaching
people dance and seeing everyone have a
great time but I have to even dig a
little bit deeper than that what is it
about dance classes that may be so happy
what may be really happy with seeing the
transformation in people seeing them
walk in not very confident in their
dance moves and then eventually being
these beautiful you know butterflies
dancing and seeing them discover who
they are and knowing that they could do
anything if they just work hard enough
that's what made me really happy
about being a dance teacher so knowing
all of that I decided to teach as many
dance classes as possible
and I did and it brought me so much joy
and happiness and at the end of the
semester when my students come up to me
and hug me I mean like really hug me to
a point that they're cutting off my
circulation it is all the accolades that
I would ever need in my life now you see
getting to that point in my life
required me to really ask myself tough
questions and also really answer them
honestly and that is what I would want
to challenge you to do you know ask
yourself the questions am I really
living my life according to my values
what are my values what makes me truly
happy why am i doing this and maybe you
have all the answers to it and you
already are living a great life and if
you are that's wonderful and I want you
to continue with that but if you're not
don't be afraid to ask yourself those
questions because the payout of that is
absolutely wonderful and beautiful so
the question of the day is what are the
changes that you have made or are going
to make to find out who you are I also
have a special shout out for Heidi how
do you thank you so much for picking up
a copy of Evans book your one word your
support means a lot to us and I really
hope you're enjoying it thank you guys
so much for watching we believe in you
and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
so give me go
you look back and you see old Arianna -
new Arianna and you think about how much
you've learned and how much you've grown
it's a shame yeah can you pinpoint one
or two things like the biggest thing
you've learned over the last maybe four
years when I guess when you just like be
yourself you know and in your most
genuine possible way and are completely
unafraid that's when everything starts
to fall into place and that takes a
while see with so much public like you
know rumors and opinions alone you know
what I mean it's like you get scared and
you want to hold back a little but then
I was like you know what like none of
this would be happening if I just showed
like just was like God and just was
myself and I went out and I was my silly
self and then you go and it all goes
away and then they're like that's me and
it's like oh yeah when you let go and
you're like here you go they gonna leave
it whether you like it or not unless it
can be like why hold back you get you
can own you one life just have fun and
be yourself and don't worry about the
rest and all falls into place honestly I
think everyone is different and unique
and that's a good thing it's not mad
it's kind of the best thing in the world
you don't want to be like everyone else
growing up in high school and just doing
your hide your whole life really either
you have been taught to feel like or you
want to be like everyone else
because conceptually you'll you'll be
included and you'll be like the crowd
but when you think about it when you
look at people like Lady Gaga who is so
crazy it's so different so unique and
her whole message is about you know
being yourself and being okay with it
and she the reason she is so successful
and so is because you talented because
she's different if she was just like
Britney Spears or if she was just like
Nina mean Nina Dobrev then there would
be two of us so there be nothing special
about that so I think what's what's
special is the fact that you're
different and is the fact that you're
unique and that you can bring something
to the table so if anything embrace that
that that uniqueness and that
that's thing that you have that no one
else does and expand upon it make it
better and tell everyone about it and be
confident because if you're confident
and happy and smiling you will attract
confidence happiness and laughter I'm
desperate for people to start defining
their hopes and dreams and wants and
needs on their terms not on what I say I
don't care if you want to hustle 18
hours a day I really don't I really
really don't I don't care if you want to
buy the nails Jess I don't care what you
want or need you need to care about what
you wanted you can't worry about what
I'm saying you can't worry about whoever
your flavor of the month is right maybe
on your flavor of the month like maybe
maybe maybe a consistent flavor of the
life is your mom's point of view is your
older brother who's guided you with
symbolism but wants you to be a lawyer
but you don't want to be a blur you want
to be a street artist you want to you
want to take the chance of being an
entrepreneur or the reverse or the
reverse I know
creatures and loves entrepreneurship
more than me but I can see you all the
time talking about like self-awareness
are you want this is the golden era for
entrepreneurship people ask me for
selfies this will go away it may not
always mean but it's going to go away
like you know it's entrepreneurship like
a rap artist like a baseball player like
the heavyweight nobody cares who the
heavyweight champion of the world is
right now nobody cares that the
astronaut
they surely did in 1969 and 1954 for a
heavyweight champ or you know they
change they change and it will always
change and it will continuously change
and right now
entrepreneurship is in this pedestal
it's having its moment and when I'm
fearful of is that you watch my videos
into my instagram quotes and what I want
to clarify for everybody is I hope you
understand I am NOT giving advice to
everybody the only advice I'd like to
give to everybody is to define what your
North Star is to understand yourself to
understand what your work-life balance
ambitions are how much what your
financial ambitions are where your
flight challenges are the problems that
you want to try to solve and cure as we
all do as humans trying to climb those
different mountains in our lives what
makes you tick that is all that matters
don't do you know I don't really be like
all these videos from YouTube you like
Emilia I don't think anybody should be
like maybe boy over there enormous
amounts of pressures and sacrifices that
I recognize you're just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else but it's also
not healthy or valuable to me to do some
of the things that you want me to do
like it's not fun for me to work 9:00 to
5:00 like I will break I will be is
equally devastated as you would be to
work till midnight every day and so we
just need a call to action for everybody
recognize we have to stop judging
everybody I'm not judging you
I'm creating content for you to use as a
barometer to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like and I'm
trying to like value my words my actions
and my content to bring the people to
ever buy their world and that's really
that's the clarification like I I don't
want people to to be likely I don't want
people to do a pile of people to do
themselves and they just have to start
with understanding themselves and not
trying to do like me of this moment or
that person the next moment that person
next moment the people that most will in
tune with themselves and figure
themselves